as darkness falls the market comes to
life a growing number of people locals
and visitors alike wander through the
labyrinth of stalls taking in the
magical Christmas atmosphere
[Music]
I like all the Christmas spirit and all
the lights and everybody's just together
and like everything's super decorated
for the holiday everybody being for the
goodwill and joy being together outside
in the cold the Nuremburg bratwurst
sausages are a must and mulled wine of
course and then looking at all the
stalls it's just special somehow this
hot cider right the market opens on the
Friday before the first Sunday of Advent
and closes on Christmas Eve every two
years the people of Nuremberg elective
Christmas angel called the Crist Kint
it's a tradition unique to Nuremberg the
christian attends various charitable
events but her most important task is to
open the Crist kindless marked the Crist
Kent invites everyone to the market and
all who come be are welcome the
tradition of the Crist continuum burg
dates back to the 1930s but the
Christmas market itself is much much
older
it was in the 16th century that
Nuremberg craftsman first set up stalls
in the central marketplace during Advent
they sold toys and sweet treats it's
basically the same now with the addition
of a few more local specialities like
the delicious Nuremberg bratwurst
sausages they sell particularly well at
Christmas as does mulled wine thousands
of liters are consumed during the
Christmas season here in Germany but
probably the most important Christmas
tradition here is Nuremberg laid Kohan
or gingerbread copies of Nuremberg
skinned less marked can be found all
over the world but they're surely no
topping the original